wow that's cool look out
[Music]
you can see a lot of the British
influence here
[Music]
good afternoon guys in Karachi Pakistan
and today I'm going to bring you into a
few different neighborhoods show you
around
it's been quite a wild trip in this
country two weeks in Pakistan and if you
want a place a city
without any tourism
here's your place
Karachi is like nothing else and I've
been to other mad hectic
crushing cities like Delhi or Mumbai and
karachi's different
I'm gonna try to explain that to you
today
and if Karachi was an instrument
it would be a bass drum that's for sure
hello sir
thank you
it would be a bass drum
people people here
have been very cool to me
shake the bag
okay
okay
Karachi five six years ago was a very
very dangerous sort of Lawless place a
bunch of gangs
Clans and other groups I don't really
know the politics of the place we're
fighting for Turf
everyone
was sort of
from the guys I've talked to they said
at night
no one is going on the street people
were even scared to move the mosque uh
for evening prayer
a real sub
and today I'm gonna start here because
it's quiet karachi's a hectic loud City
and so you can hear me and then we'll
get into the streets into the people
into the life check out a few
neighborhoods have no idea where this is
going
but Karachi is one of those places that
it's impossible to be bored
things will happen
and activity is there for the camera
that's for sure
dope
and that's a stylish cap very nice
these are the Pakistani Rangers the
Rangers are
the Elite Force here that keep
things secure
and
unless I got this wrong locals tell me
it's a good thing to see Rangers around
they don't seem bought off or corrupt
but I'm a tourist I don't know for sure
selfie
selfie
okay
thank you
America good yeah
nice to meet you thank you thank you
two weeks two weeks in Pakistan good
yeah very good alone yes
what did you say thank you for coming in
our country thank you buddy you guys
have been awesome yeah YouTuber yes what
are your name what are your names
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
body bizarre this is one of the center
points I believe
and it's rather uncomfortable right now
with the camera so we're gonna look at
some fruits
oh nice
oh I'm good thank you thank you
quick Icebreaker
I'm wondering what I was doing with the
camera
I understand that what am I doing with
the camera trying to show
what these streets look like and I think
many people
question why which is understandable
because everyone sees the world through
their their lens their perspective
and maybe they don't see what's
extraordinary or different
but coming from where I come from
it's obviously much different
and interesting
and this is just
oh wow a lot of the exploration here
looks like an old British building I'm
guessing over there
nice to meet you thank you what's your
name Peter Peter
thanks so much yeah okay sabash take
care
all right
very friendly very friendly and that's
the gem
Pakistan is the fact that people are
very outgoing welcoming curious
and like that and that's what you want
when you're traveling to a country
nice to meet you
want to feel like Brad Pitt
or
any famous star
and you're not and then Pakistan's the
place to go
because really people uh
give you attention never alone in this
country that's for sure got a nice piece
of architecture here you can see a lot
of the British influence here
in these Alleyways
cool Old World style
and then you come down
into the market
a little quieter back here this is nice
this is this is peaceful hello
USA nice to meet you nice to meet you
thank you love it yeah very cool very
good experience I don't think weak
people
can survive here uh it hits you pretty
hard hello
it hits you pretty hard this city with
all all the stimulation all the senses
get hammered in this country Pakistan
America
people say New York City doesn't sleep
those people have not been to Karachi
here we go here's a very cool building
packed with Commerce
everything you can think of given an ID
got an idea
TV remotes
socks books Within
a one minute walk of one minute of
walking you can get pretty much
everything you need I if I wasn't making
videos I'd be wearing one of these
yourself in
[Music]
thank you
this is called Empress Market Empress
market right sir
fruit
nice marble stairs
spices
they're allowed this place is
foreign
it's like there's an echoing effect that
takes place
inside one's head
we got here
potatoes
potatoes and lemon
[Music]
mosque over here
I've read the greater metropolitan areas
23 24 million people
and of all places in the world that I've
been
so like
like crushed
side of the city
when you're in the center of Karachi
you can almost feel the weight
of the whole city
it's not a bad thing I'm just saying
it's like um it's a very intense place
there's no public transport so there is
no Metro the bus service is like this I
don't know if that's a city thing
bus right here
or if people just own buses I'm not sure
on that one oh you got some oil issues
oh the uh the brake
definitely want that to work
bye-bye everyone Smiles everyone waves I
mean what cities have uh
20 plus million does that happening
wow that's cool look how the roof just
sort of
tapers back the condition not perfect
but the design is so cool look at this
fine here
it just tapers back nice balconies
that's streamlined modern look on the
corner it takes a little bit of
imagination because things are falling
apart but you can see that it's
quite cool I hope they restore these
in a way this is super easy vlogging
because you just kind of run the camera
hello
you just run the camera and there's
something there
in another way it's super hard because
[Music]
look around
obviously the only white bald guy on the
streets talking a different language
and into a camera
so it attracts attention
and as much as
the vibe here is overall good and people
are cool
of course there's some bad apples out
there so you got to be on your guard to
some degree
friendly enough to have people open up
like that so what is this
is a chicken chicken
wow that looks good and then it's fried
yeah it's a fried
looks quite tasty
one but I get you one okay okay
I'll get you one buddy on the monkey I
hate monkeys what
money okay one one thank you
guys there you go the wealthy people
really more than anywhere I've been
break themselves away
like they're off in gated communities
far from all of this
this parathi
paparazzi
it was very good
nice protein from the eggs good amount
of spice
crispy flaky
Joey's shell
quite oily it is Pakistan everything's
very oily here but good
thank you thank you sir okay thank you
thank you Pakistan just ask the guys the
police officer how this neighborhood
how this neighborhood is and
they said
it's good you're our guests
protected
cops have all been very cool the cops
the Rangers
special forces are all over the place
the isi don't really know who those guys
are because you can't you just don't
know they're
Undercover
very much yes nice hit
very much take care bye-bye
see you guys
Cricket in the alleyway
and Karachi is one of those cities where
there are all these little veins
okay I call them veins but streets or
Alleyways and on each Street there's
just a full community everyone knows
everybody
kids all play with each other it's that
old world
that old
stuff that's very
incredible
I like it like it's very much connected
hahaha
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here we are in a park looks like a
cricket park everyone's playing cricket
absolutely love their Cricket in this
country
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Beach this is a beach destination in the
city we've got some celebration going on
here
and what is this
you can see on my way over here
and with some of the buildings here
there's more money in this neighborhood
at least for the accommodations ports
off in the distance
and here we are a beach
thank you thank you one more one more
okay
a unique Beach experience I gotta say I
don't know what this is this is like
it's not sand it's not mud it's
probably has some oil in it
what are we shooting here I don't want
to be on the other side of this
morning shooting balloons okay
we got quite a bit going on here
all sorts of things being sold I don't
know what those are
different games
people out in the water
a camel I don't know if you can see that
out there there's a camel
four-wheeler action
bug stairs
you ready
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you want me to ride the camel
I don't like those things scare me they
scare me
I don't like camel so much it's a
beautiful
yes yeah
it's a beautiful outfit
from swats
beautiful place beautiful
I'm not ready for that I don't like
camels but it's beautiful
[Music]
pack of dogs
back there
all right guys
come to Karachi
if you want the bass drum
if you want the ultimate intense place
Karachi is your place
love these people
well that's it guys Dan Karachi
and I think I conveyed a little bit what
this place is about only scratch the
service obviously until next one
[Music]
thank you